en raison des nombreuses nouvelles
politiques de la campagne électorale et
c'était on avait fait une pause de
musique voilà le retour des choix de
rebecca bonsoir et bk bonsoir parce
qu'il ya très longtemps
ça fait très longtemps voix se dépêcher
overclockant électorale lui tombe dessus
et permettent
on commence avec philippe b oui fait les
bébés pour bergeron auteur compositeur
interprète originaire de rouyn noranda
mais cap et à montréal depuis des lunes
et qui avait eu des critiques
dithyrambiques avec son album précédent
variations fantômes s'était élancé en
musique classique bon dans son fond et
cette fois ci c'est autre chose
ornithologie la nuit après l'album
rupture l'album ou qui suit donc la
quête de bonheur en écoutant les godets
enfin
cool et lâche ample
verdi au sens d une inspiration de
richard desjardins que d'ailleurs son
voisin s'allumant et puis c'est vraiment
ce que je préfère en fait je pense que
si ce sont les deux philippe et ses
rondeurs très en demande est très
polyvalent aussi il était guitariste de
pierre lapointe dû réaliser premier
album des chars boulet il a composé la
trame sonore du film chasse au goddard
d'abitibi en ce moment il en train de
peaufiner la réalisation avec benjamin
biolay de l'album hommage à serge
reggiani d'isabelle boulay c'est
vraiment un gros touche à tout ok bon
vent dans tandem tous d'accord là vu la
disparue
et
sous l'ére temps
t les oiseaux perdu
traîne les rues
et koné lisa leblanc oui oui duo radio
radio radio radio pour parler acadien
donc un an
un autre groupe l'airé belize que j'aime
beaucoup trio acadien qui avait qui se
fait en fait sur un mini album depuis
deux ans elles ont gagné les
francouvertes l'an dernier et puis la
tournée en france tournée en suisse lit
depuis la semaine dernière un premier
vrai album intitulé mon petit coin
tiens
priot cadets à la base on à guitares
banjo ukulélé et puis le réalisateur
françois lafontaine a ajouté clavier la
psy aux percussions sont plus rond mon
rôle c'est crade les titres de référence
pour mal du fait de la pression
constamment sur le vote elles sont
utilisées à la mode c'est très clair du
rhône mais il ya des gens qui disent que
parler de l'exode rural aussi ses traits
à l'approché des chansons est une ligue
wac est banques notamment et moi c'est
peut-être parce que ma mère est née à
saint quentin au nouveau brunswick
j'utilise la cad acadienne qui peut même
toucher directement mais j'ai adoré
on écoute en outre ok j'ai vanté manche
j'ai là
bene
j'attends maintenant
bbb et l'a mis là vous parlez de dire
oui aux premières vous avez exactement
minidisc ils viennent d'en lancer un
autre cette semaine le lancement a lieu
ce soir deuxième ep
c'est là dessus très bien
et